and minimalists hello everybody welcome
to the minimalist podcast where we
discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less my name is
Joshua Fields Milburn and I'm Ryan
Nicodemus and together we are the
minimalists welcome today we're gonna
talk about your insecurities Ryan what
are you looking at my insecurities talk
about criticism we're gonna talk about
perceived failures we're gonna talk
about redefining success and we're gonna
answer your questions with today's guest
our friend Griffin house is here in the
studio hey guys all the way from where
did you just come from I came from Santa
Barbara today but I've been in Denmark
and London and but it's on his shirt
where he really came from it's right
born and raised Ohio so this is this is
how we know Griffin y'all is so Josh and
I grew up in Dayton Ohio in the suburbs
and so did Griffin and we used to go to
all his concerts that's kind of where he
grew up to now he's in Nashville because
you know that's what happens as you get
older to get more famous you move out of
Dayton y'all there though you said y'all
they say y'all Nashville well yes well
you know we we grew up in Lebanon which
is it's closer to Cincinnati than Dayton
okay but it's still considered a suburb
of Dayton so you know that's my way of
saying we just grew up closer to that
Kentucky border yeah well Springfield
Spring tucky well Griffin we're gonna
answer some questions that I hope you'll
help us dive into these our first
question today is from Cedric he's a
patreon subscriber from Quebec Canada
I'm a musician and I've been writing
songs for a bit now I do want feedback
on my work but I feel insecure asking
people around me as I want them to be
brutally honest but I'm not always 100%
sure that they are
I actually feel more secure on a stage
in front of total strangers then
one-on-one talking about my songs so I
guess my question is for you guys being
writers what are your steps for getting
inputs on your work imagining like
during that voice mail he was uh you
know on a bench press will put chains on
the bar I think it's what he was doing
what it was I don't know anyway Griffin
you you say you're a musician and does
that resonate with you sometimes he
feels more comfortable in front of a
crowd of a hundred or a thousand people
than sharing something intimate with
someone who's close to you
sure I there's so many times when I feel
like real life is really awkward and
I've played so many shows that stepping
out in front of an audience it's like
you've hit the on button and the choice
to be all these things or have these
little eccentricities or tics kind of
have to go away because it's either sink
or swim so you really don't have a
choice unless you just want to fall flat
on your face right so so so like how do
you how do you decipher between like
valuable feedback and just flat-out like
criticism especially in the early stages
of developing your music because you
know like like he was saying you know he
wants to go to friends and families in
the early stages he wants to get some
feedback but there's also this
trepidation of like you know you don't
wanna get shredded either right I was
just thinking while he was asking that
question that it occurred to me in the
very beginning when I started it it
never even dawned on me that somebody
wouldn't like what I was doing or they
would be credit they would be critical I
was just I wanted to do it so badly that
I did not care what anybody thought I
was just gonna do it I remember sitting
in one of my first gigs I was playing at
Jack Quinn's Irish pub for some tips and
some Guinness and a bar tab and I looked
over at this lady I was playing an
original song and I saw her leaned over
at her friend and I could see her read
her lips and she said this guy sucks and
I stopped what I was doing I was like
lady I'm playing an original song here
what do you want to hear look some James
Taylor or something like some cover with
song and I just got mad at her because I
was doing what I wanted to be doing and
I was defending myself like it all costs
so what if for whatever reason I just
knew I wanted to do it now as I've
gotten older I don't know if there's
good thing or bad thing but it's gotten
worse now when I think because well when
I put myself out there for new things
like by podcasts that started for
instance I feel way more self-critical
and vulnerable than I do that when I
started with my music and I it's it's
still kind of that way
guess music not so much but other ways I
can relate to feeling like am I gonna
say something wrong
I mean even being here right now it's
like oh man what if I don't know the
protocol here like that it's everything
he makes it sound really crazy toward
everyone but what I'm hearing you say is
is like you you be yourself as much as
possible and you do it for you
especially when it came to your music
it's not like you were doing for that
that lady sitting at the bar sure you
want to make people happy with your
music you want people to like your music
but really it was doing something that
you love to do and set I mean Cedric can
totally take something away from this
meaning Cedric if you are putting
creations out there that you truly feel
good about you can look in the mirror
and be like man this is good I really
like it that's that's what matters is if
you like it Cedric there are gonna be
critics there are gonna be people who
give you some feedback and I think I
like with Josh and I that's what we have
I think we do a really good job of
deciphering between those two bits we
can decipher between criticism and what
feedback is criticism is like you know a
seagull coming in and like sitting on
your work and then flying off and then
feedback is like that lady though this
guy sucks it's it's not helpful at all
right where feedback is saying something
like oh hey that was a great song or hey
Ryan that was a great podcast but you
know what that light was really glaring
in the YouTube video like I mean there
is you can tell when someone is trying
to give you a legitimate piece of
feedback whether it's whether it is
legitimate or not I mean if they present
it in a kind way I'll at least consider
what they're saying but when someone
comes into there like oh man this guy
sucks it's like what do you say to that
yeah well you would I mean what you said
we I wasn't there for that lady that
that's the thing that's great like I was
there for me and I think it's when I go
back to that person at 22 I'm like how
bad did you want to do that and that guy
really really wanted to do that so for
Cedric I would say like how bad do you
do you want to do this if you really
want to do it then nobody can nobodies
opinion is going to be able to stop you
from doing what your heart is just
really yearning to do that's sweet that
podcast Ron I was great I think I think
ultimately feedback builds us up or has
the potential to build us up and
criticism is meant to tear us down
and that's how I sort of separates to
feedback comes with a solution to a
problem criticism just shows up with
with the problem right and and so if
you're able to separate that and say is
this person trying to build me up or
trying to tear me down if they're trying
to tear me down then you know what that
criticism it's not for you even like
professional criticism you have people
write about your records before and I'm
sure while every review has been glowing
in a hypothetical world where there
isn't a glowing review that's the one
you Neuros over like you can get ten
great reviews and the one that has a
little cavil in it in your life that's
right they didn't understand me they
didn't get it but the thing is those
reviews even the professional critics
it's not for you the artist it's for a
general populace or whomever and it's
also for them it's reflecting their own
views about a body of work they might
may have just been bored that day and
it's easier to be critical than it is
it's it's just more fun for them to
chair something apart than it is to take
your time and listen to it and they have
a bad day and it's like all sudden you
take it personally you know like that
can happen to you also that aggregates
more eyeballs onto their their what
they're writing if everything they're
right is like a happy-go-lucky story
Griffin house releases another awesome
elbows impossible to give it six stars
and so the easier route to those
eyeballs is a salacious story it's it's
the reason you know the politics right
now is is so popular it's not it's not
news it's entertainment and and we're
being entertained with that and it's
also entertaining to see someone tear an
artist a musician a podcaster down I see
to see them tear that person down
we like grab our popcorn I don't want to
watch this yeah I love that approach man
like because when you're having a
conversation with so especially when
it's a face-to-face conversation and
that's the type of interaction it sounds
like Cedric is going for like these
close friends and family getting
feedback you can tell when someone is
trying to build you up or when they're
trying to tear you down yes indeed
Cedric I'd love to send you a copy of
our book essential it's an essay
collection with a hundred and fifty
different essays where is it
this one here it's our biggest book
actually it is our biggest book but if
you like our podcast you will like the
audiobook version of essential it 150
different essays twelve different
chapters about twelve areas of
intentional living and one of those
chapters are actually the two chapters I
think that'll really stand out here for
Cedric the first one is about success as
an entire chapter about redefining
success I want to talk to Griffin about
that and a little bit today but also a
chapter on priorities we're also going
to spend some time today talking about
priorities and reprioritizing to make
sure we're creating what we want to
create so Cedric I hope you enjoy the
audiobook version of that or if you want
the book book or the eBook version we're
happy to send those to you as well Ryan
with time as a you know what time it is
it it's time for our lightning round
where we answer questions from social
media Griffin you participated with this
a little bit in Nashville right though
that one stop do you remember what we
did here yes okay cool so what we try to
do is we try to answer questions in a
short shareable lesson 140 character
response but that's not what we really
do we just monitor on a bit so people
send in their questions we're at the
minimalists on Twitter Facebook and
Instagram and you are at Griffin house
music at Griffin Wade houses my
Instagram on Instagram and on Twitter
you are Griffin house Griffin house and
you're also on Facebook in my space I'm
still following he's it he's my top
eight on MySpace I ran our first
question our first question is from Zack
how do you work through trying to make
your work perfect man so my pithy answer
to this my minimal maxim is perfect is
the Nemesis of meaningful now if there's
what this weird sort of almost bell
curve right Griffin when you first
started making music and were you in
Oxford or in Cincinnati or somewhere
around there right yeah I was in
probably in Oxford that's where I first
started writing songs and I am a
university I mean yes so so when you
first started writing songs well you you
alluded to this a moment ago you said it
never occurred to me that other people
would think this was bad ever right and
so there's a weird thing when you first
start creating everything that you
create in your own mind is somewhat
brilliant and I don't know if you
victim to that well it felt impossible
at the very beginning it was like I was
listening to you to records or something
go how do you make a song like this out
of words on a page
and a couple chords is like there's
there's no way I'm going to be able to
do this no I just you just stick with it
and somehow something an idea pops you
know out of nowhere and you follow that
somewhere and it's almost still like
that today but but if your idea of
perfect is like when you first start
writing music like this has to be u2 or
or do nothing well then you're just
going to do nothing yeah right and and
if you do nothing you're certainly not
going to do anything meaningful and I
think for me and for Ryan too because
we've talked about this personally we
need to be able to look ourselves in the
mirror and say this is the best I could
do given the the resources I had at that
particular time as you've got your your
this is your new album natural man is
what your seven eight ninth album
depends on how you count them right yeah
with all the EPS and other stuff in
there yeah so so you have a dozen bodies
of work Wilson will call it however many
of those are albums or whatever it's
confusing these days especially in the
digital world
but you have that many bodies of work
and each one is an evolution of Griffin
house in a way and going back and
looking at it's almost like this time
capsule if you go back to Lost and Found
which is I'm a dozen years ago or
something right and and you look at that
record and you're like okay I believe
that's the best I could do at the time
is it a perfect record was there is
there such a thing no but but it is it
captures this moment so well that you
couldn't even make a lost-and-found now
nor would you want to necessarily yeah
so like do you when you give yourself
permission to like put it out there
because I know that you've had a ton of
different experiences with doing
independent records with record labels
trying to tell you what you need to put
on your album so I guess I guess there
when do you look in the mirror and
you're like you know what Griffin do it
let it go well we didn't have the luxury
to sit around and make something perfect
because when I made my first records
there wasn't a record label sitting
there with a $200,000 budget that just
said
said stay in the studio for a year and
finish when it's perfect and so we did
the best that we could with what we had
and we usually had two weeks to record
in case of lost and found my friends
played for free after it's a long story
but they offered to do that and we had
there's one song on that record that I
think is almost the perfect recording
and it was this live recording of
waterfall and the rest of the songs on
that album are like those aren't even
recorded close to as good as they could
be there's some of them I can't stand
listening to because I know that could
be so much better but you get lucky and
maybe something close to perfect happens
once in a while and the other ones you
just have to do the best that you can
and and move on and it's not set in
stone forever either you know you know
what's magic and those imperfections do
where as if everything has this the
glossiest patina that sometimes loses
the essence of what the thing is about
yeah you your record even before that
one Upland I think it was called yeah
which was like I mean an elaborate demo
in a way but but those songs there's a
certain analog quality to them that no
you don't want to replicate that now
with what you're doing but but it
captured exactly what you were going
through just even as a musician in that
moment I feel like sure yeah I think
sometimes so you gotta let go you got to
let go of these little creations like
I'm thinking about the documentary that
we filmed with Matt we got the team we
got the crowd you know Matt did the best
that he could with this this this
footage and it was a really really good
film but it wasn't near perfect and Josh
and I and Matt and the rest of the team
had to look at that and say okay is
there something we can do to make this
better it's where we can release it or
should we just let this let this
creation go and for you know by and
large like we have to we have to let it
go so let me ask you Griffin like when
you look at like your twelfth album
album versus your first album like do
you look at your first album like oh man
like like I can't believe I put that out
there and like feel way better about
like your 12th album or yet something I
feel both sometimes I look back and I go
oh I was singing really weird my voice
sounds strange why am i pronouncing
things like that my younger so
was kind of awkward or this was this
recording just sounds bad likewise that
drum sound like that and this sounds
sort of out of tune or the tone is harsh
and now we're better at some things like
that but there's also you you have some
sort of wild reckless thing that happens
when you're just naive and you don't
really know what you're doing and you
you have almost more belief or freedom
to do stuff in a way that feels really
inspired so we just did the best that we
could back then I feel like it was more
important to put something out and get
it out there than it was to sit around
for a decade and try to like master
something perfectly and I've often
thought and now like well how cool it
would would it be to work on something
like tires tirelessly and like try to
get a masterpiece but the the right
decision
moving forward has always been just
finished something up and like do the
best that you can in the short term let
it be as good as it can and then move on
yeah theory about art you don't get to
determine what your masterpieces oh you
don't
really and the for us like for me I
always thought it was this book
everything that remains and I feel the
same way like for me
actually there are parts of this where I
look at this and this my 32 year old
self wrote it and in writing it I
couldn't redo that at 37 now it's it's
I'm just a different person at this
point but it did capture the best of me
in fact I've had four false starts
writing trying to write a book a
follow-up book to this but they haven't
worked because it's like man I said
everything I need to say in this one
book and it's hard to sort of keep it
going in fact we have a question about
that little bit later but Ryan I'll let
you get to your pithy answers because
we're almost out of time here
cool pit the answer is perfection is
impossible adding value is priceless so
Zac what I'm trying to tell you is is
yes put something out there man like do
the best job that you can with the
constraints that you have in fact if you
don't have any constraints try to put a
constraint on there to kind of force
yourself to put something out there but
except that it's never gonna be perfect
and also know like as you continue to
put stuff out five years from now you're
gonna be so much better if you wait five
years and don't put anything out you're
not gonna feel nearly as good all right
next question is from chocolate mmm
chocolate how do you defeat shyness and
self-doubt well I don't have to put the
answer for this one but I could tell you
the one thing that I did because I'm an
extreme introvert like I spent 80 90
percent of my time alone I I value that
alone time but I was also very socially
incompetent like in high school and the
thing that I did was I got a job that
make made me work with people every
single day and it's it's you know when
you teach a baby to swim you can just
literally throw them in the water I know
you can't it just sounds funny
no babies in the water but if you if you
don't do it if you wait till they're 2
or 3 then they drown but if you do with
it with an infant you can sit my mom did
this with me and just I I think she was
trying to get rid of me but she just
chucked me in the water and you start
swimming and I found that that's what
happens when you're forced into a
situation like that I mean at some point
you you were busking in Cincinnati and
that was like in order to get good in
front of you don't just start I mean
maybe some people do you know these are
these sort of industry plants but for
the most part people don't start playing
in front of crowds of a thousand people
you're playing in front of a crowd of
one who has to be walking by right now
yeah did have you you don't come across
as like a shy or timid person to me but
have you is that something you've had to
fight through yourself I'm an introvert
as well so that's what when you ask me
the question before about stepping on
stage and if that feels like more
natural yeah because in in my normal
life I'm an introvert and then all of a
sudden when I do what I do and have to
get on stage and talk to people after
the show or before you have to become an
extrovert right and and be more outgoing
and so I think that's good to have that
balance for some reason but I think it's
I think it's a great point man um so
well here's my opinion sir if you
relentlessly practice failing you'll
eventually stop feeling like a failure
and I think that's really where this
shyness and self-doubt leads us it's
it's we get afraid of failure but if you
practice and practice and practice maybe
you're not the awesome and you know an
awesome extra extrovert the first time
you go out there and try to be an
extrovert but the more you
just the better you get at it like I'm
thinking dude can you imagine if our
first event was like the Sydney crowd no
I had to pass out to 2,000 people I
remember the first time we spoke in
front of 8 people it was like who's to
say right and you know I don't even
think it's necessarily about
extraversion though so much as it is
like you could still be an introvert
who's socially competent right and
people often think that I'm an extrovert
because I I can interact with people in
a in a social setting I just can't do it
for long stretches of time because it
drains me whereas with Ryan it
completely like gives him his energy and
and we're different in that way but we
can both be socially confident the
opposite is also true you can be an
extrovert who's totally socially
incompetent - there's going around being
you know the ass of the party so to
speak which I yeah also can be sometimes
it looks like we have several more
surprise questions this week about the
myth of job security about developing
higher standards and developing
confidence we got a question here about
growing as a creative person and I want
to chat with Griffin about a recent
conversation that he and I had over text
message about feeling like a failure and
if you want to hear all that you can
listen to this week's maximal episode
available exclusively on patreon that's
right you're currently listening to our
weekly minimal episode but each week
Ryan and I record an entirely different
long-form maximal episode on the
minimalists private podcast which gives
us the private space we need to discuss
the topics that we don't typically
discuss in public Plus patreon is the
best way for us to fund this podcast and
keep it 100 percent advertisement free
when you subscribe to the minimalists
private podcast on patreon you'll
receive a personal link so that our
maximal episodes play in your favorite
podcast app you also get our entire back
catalog of more than 100 private podcast
episodes find all the details and all
the good stuff including an additional
podcast episode every week over at the
minimalists comm slash support and now
here are some voicemail comments and
tips from our listeners hi my name is
Lisa and I'm calling from Maryland I
really just wanted to give a comment I
have listened to your podcast for about
a year and have enjoyed many of them
thank you and I also just wanted to make
a comment in reference to
family friends and gifts my
granddaughter will be 4 in August and my
gen-y daughter is a budding minimalist
and as a result of that is trying to
reduce the number of gifts coming into
her home so she did a an invitation and
indicated that there could be donations
made to the NICU which my granddaughter
resided in for a brief period of time
after her birth or give a donation to
her college fund we were discussing the
backlash that she received from people
that she worked with who came up to her
and told her that she was denying her
child a childhood and a variety of other
rather negative responses I'm proud of
my daughter she's holding tight and
holding fast and will continue to use
this option for my granddaughter's
birthday but it was interesting to
actually see this firsthand
as opposed to just you know hearing
about it on the podcast
hi guys my name is Alicia Aiken I'm
calling from byron minnesota I'm calling
because I listen to the pocket oh I love
your podcast but I it was listening to
the clothing episode at this weekend and
I have a good really really good
recommendation to help find women's
clothing that is responsibly made
there's a blogger that basically she
works as an ethicist and then this is
like her side passion but if you go to
the garments EA she's Canadian
so V garment dot CA you can see her
website in a blog and also you can find
out the garment life at Instagram other
companies that I personally love are ace
and Jake and their stuff is expensive
but really cool and beautiful fabrics
it's all ethically made and I also
really like bridge and burn from
Portland anyways just thought maybe that
would be helpful
alright y'all that is almost it for this
episode thanks again the griffin house
for joining us today make sure you check
out his new album it's called natural
man and real quick 4 right here right
now here's one thing that's going on in
the life of the minimalists you can
check out our side project it's called
minimalism life we recently redesigned
the entire site to make it more clear
more focused more beautiful basically
the three functions there there are the
journal articles we have a community of
different minimalist who write about
their different minimalist perspectives
we also have inspirational wallpapers
really beautiful wallpapers for your
desktop or your phone over there and
they're free you can download them for
free and also the there's a new feature
called inside and minimalism it is a
letter that we publish regularly you can
find all the details over at minimalism
dot life that is the website there the
URL minimalism dot life if you have a
question comment or minimalism tip for
our podcast leave us a voicemail for
zero six two one nine seven eight three
nine or send a voice memo to podcast at
the minimalists comm you can comment on
this episode at youtube.com slash the
minimus if you want our show notes on
your inbox sign up for our email list
over at the minimalists comm just enter
your email address there at the top
you'll also receive our simple Sunday
emails each week for our added value
this week I'm going to play
you out with my favorite Griffin house
song it's a song called army from his
album Lost and Found and if you leave
here today with just one message we hope
it's this love people and use things
because the opposite never works thanks
for listen y'all and minimus